In Three.js there are a number of ways to set a color. See the additional course
materials for a link to the documentation. We'll cover four of them here. You
start by defining the material. We'll talk more later about what this material
does. For now, just know that you can set a color for it. If you don't set any
at all, the default is white. The MeshLambertMaterial object that you've just
created has several different parameters. This can be set when you first create
the object or later in a number of different ways. One of these parameters is
the material's color. These parameters have type THREE.Color and you can use all
the methods associated with it. One method is to set the r, g and b channels
separately. Here I'm setting the color to red. This directly sets the variables
r, g, and b in the color attribute to the desired values. I can also use the
setRGB method on the color class, setting the color to orange. A more compact
way to set a color is to use hexidecimal numbers. Here I'm setting a bright
blue. The value 0x1280FF is a single number holding the red, green, and blue
channels all together. Let's break it down. The 0x prefix means that this is
hexidecimal number, base 16. Where the letter a means 10, b means 11, on up to f
meaning 15. If you don't know about hexidecimals, see the additional course
materials for a link to more information. 3 channels, r, g, and b, are each
encoded in order. Trading each 2 digits as the channel's value. For example, the
red channel is one two in hexadecimal. This means 1, 16 plus 2, to give 18 in
decimal value. Green is computed in a similar fashion. 8 times 16 plus 0 gives
the level of 128. Blue is at the maximum, ff, adding up to 255. Each of these
values can range from 0 to 255. The range 0 to 255 is used, because most
computer monitors have 8-bits of precision for each color channel. 2 to the 8th
power is 256. So the range 0 to 255 is the entire range of possible color
channel values. So, once you have a color you like, in Three.js, you can
conveniently just paste it into place. In fact there's a way of initializing the
material to color it when you create it. When you put something in braces like
this, you're initializing that variable in the object to the given value. This
particular hexidecimal value gives a yellow color. Note that the hexidecimal
letters, such as the f's here, can be upper or lower case. It doesn't matter. I
tend to use upper case as it makes it more readable.